[Musik]
landtagswahl in rheinland pfalz wie
steht es um den ausbau des internets
besonders im ländlichen raum
dreis-brück mitten in der vulkaneifel
hier sprechen wir über das thema
wirtschaft und digitale infrastruktur in
dreis brück leben rund 1000 menschen die
einen pendeln zur arbeit nach trier oder
koblenz
die anderen haben einen job hier hier
treffe ich heute roman schütz er wohnt
und arbeitet in dem kleinen eifelort
römern schütz ist bauingenieur direkt
neben seinem wohnhaus hat er sein
planungsbüro seit 2008 ist er
selbstständig zusammen mit seinem
mitarbeiter und seiner mitarbeiterin
plant er ein und mehrfamilienhäuser aber
auch gewerbegebäude alles läuft hier
digital baupläne visualisiert in 3d für
auftraggeber und kunden wie lange dauert
das wenn sie so etwas vermeiden möchten
also wenn ich auch so in mode modell ein
3d pdf mache die haben ganz schnell mal
50 oder 100 mb sind wir schnell bei 15
15 minuten manchmal oder nächsten halt
immer ganz schlechtes priesters zwischen
roland schütz hat hier noch eine
kupferleitung dementsprechend langsam
ist seine internetverbindung große
datenmengen verschickt er deshalb nachts
wenn die leitungen nicht so ausgelastet
sind trotzdem kommt es immer wieder vor
dass daten nicht ankommen dann bekommt
man dann eine woche später ein anruf und
heißt wo sind die unterlagen wir
brauchen die sofort ja und dann setzt
sich heraus okay die man ist nicht
durchgegangen also wir haben ja partner
auch in regensburg und in berlin setzen
zum beispiel könnten auch vielleicht
noch weiter in deutschland aktiv sein
aber das geht halt unter umständen
deswegen ist das ist einfach vom
standort nachteil dass schlussendlich
trotzdem weg aus dreis brück möchte der
45 jährige nicht
er ist in der eifel geboren hat hier
sein haus lange saniert wohnt hier mit
seiner frau und seinen zwei kindern
was wünschen sie sich denn konkret jetzt
von der politik das wäre auf jeden fall
wichtig für home arbeitsplätze für
kleine unternehmen mittelständische
unternehmen auch auf kleinen dörfern
oder kleineren gemeinden tasten gutes
internet da ist und wenn wir auch den
ländlichen raum stärken wollen geht das
nur über das schnelle internet
das thema digitale infrastruktur alle im
landtag vertretenen parteien fordern
einen schnelleren ausbau der netze
glasfaser ist das mittel der wahl doch
die ansätze unterscheiden sich es ist
auch ganz interessant zu sehen dass die
regierungsparteien hier vor allen dingen
die spd aber auch die fdp die im
ministerium auch zuständig gewesen ist
für dieses thema natürlich erstmal auf
die erzielten fortschritte verweisen
aber auch deutlich machen das muss jetzt
noch schneller vorangehen
die fdp verfolgt hier einen eher markt
förmigen ansatz indem sie darauf setzt
anreize für den für die investitionen in
den netzausbau zu setzen
bei den grünen ist es ein thema das vor
allen dingen auch wichtig ist für die
klima- und energiewende
die oppositionsparteien verweisen auf
die defizite in sachen glasfaserausbau
bei der cdu soll digitalisierung zur
chefsache gemacht werden indem man hier
auch entsprechende zuständigkeiten
schafft die afg hingegen prangert die
versäumnisse in deutlich schärferen
worten an belässt es dann aber bei
plakativen vorschlägen wie sie das
ändern möchte beispielsweise durch
glasfaser gutscheine bis es auch in der
eifel flächendeckend glasfaser netz gibt
wird roman schütz wohl noch warten
müssen
zumal konkrete zeitpläne in den
wahlprogrammen fehlen
ein fruchtbares blockieren um obst
anzubauen das ist heidesheim beim 1 doch
so idyllisch wie es klingt ist es nicht
immer so mancher landwirt hat ein
problem er muss auf der einen seite
wirtschaftlich produzieren und sich auf
der anderen seite mit naturschutz und
insektenschutz auseinandersetzen
dass das nicht immer ganz einfach so
erzählt es uns kirsten werner die 37
jährige führt einen obsthof der seit
generationen in familienhand ist noch
sind die bäume auf ihren 38 hektar kahl
doch im sommer wachsen hier acht
verschiedene obstsorten das credo der
landwirte verträglich mit der natur
wirtschaften
ich habe hier ein ökologisch
integrierten betrieb das heißt so viel
wie nötig so wenig wie möglich
ich betreibe hier ganz normal
pflanzenschutz auf meinen bäumen wenn
ich sehe dass schad erreger bei ihnen
sind auf ihn sind vollständig auf
spritzmittel verzichten das geht einfach
nicht sagt sie in der natur gibt es
nette schädlinge oder nette insekten
genauso wie es nicht nette insekten gibt
und in dem moment wo die
verhältnismäßigkeit einfach nicht mehr
da ist möchte muss und darf ich meine
bäume unterstützen mit diesem schädling
umzugehen
andernfalls würde ihre wirtschaftliche
grundlage wegbrechen obst mit maden will
schließlich keiner
doch es gibt das bestreben in der
politik den einsatz von insektiziden
weiter zu begrenzen
kirsten werner befürchtet weitere
einschränkungen und wünscht sich mehr
augenmaß
das ist ja nicht ausschließt sich die
landwirtschaft die in meinen augen sogar
mit einem großen fragezeichen für das
insekten sterben verantwortlich ist
sondern es gibt so viele andere faktoren
die einfach überhaupt nicht betrachtet
werden und dass ein imker aus
norddeutschland jedes jahr seine
bienenvölker zu ihr bringt ist für die
obstbäuerin ein zeichen dass sie beim
insektenschutz vieles richtig macht
darüber würde sie auch gern mit der
politik reden
ich wünsche mir ganz konkret dass wir
hier einbezogen werden dass man mit uns
zusammenarbeitet dass man mit uns
zusammen die natur entwickelt das waren
aber auf der anderen seite auch mit uns
zusammenarbeitet was die regionalität
angeht dass wir hier weiterhin für uns
produzieren dürfen und können und wir
nicht die stellschraube so stark
angezogen bekommen dass das nicht mehr
der fall ist
ein konkretes problem und konkrete
wünsche an die politiker im
landtagswahlkampf haben viele parteien
sich zum insektenschutz positioniert die
spd schlägt eine stärkung von
blühstreifen programmen vor
auch einen verstärkten einsatz von
ökologisch verträglichen
pflanzenschutzmitteln ganz interessant
ist dass das thema bei der fdp eher als
urbanes hitlers thema rüberkommt bei den
grünen finden sich ganz konkret
vorschläge auch wie sich die bürger dazu
einbringen können ehrenamtliche insekten
schützer nisthilfen bau und ähnliches
mehr
einzig die cdu in rheinland-pfalz äußert
sich nicht speziell zum thema insekten
und was es mit der landwirtschaft welche
ideen haben die parteien da die spd
möchte vor allen dingen den
konventionellen und den ökologischen
landbau zusammenbringen die
unterstützung regionaler erzeuger und
die vermarktung der produkte wird in dem
zusammenhang groß geschrieben das findet
sich ähnlich auch bei den anderen
parteien die afg verweist vor allen
dingen auf die bedrohung der bäuerlichen
landwirtschaft durch globalisierter
agrarmärkte und möchte dass insekten
sterben wissenschaftlich
genauer untersuchen die landwirtschaft
und ihre herausforderungen für die
parteien ebenso wie für kirsten werner
ein wichtiges thema wem sie bei der wahl
am sonntag ihre stimme gibt hat sie noch
nicht entschieden
hierhin soll stand märz 2021 die brücke
im malerischen mittelrheintal kommen
falls sie denn irgendwann mal gebaut
wird
die diskussion ob eine brücke im
mittelrheintal gebaut wird sie geht seit
jahrzehnten und das ist nicht
übertrieben zu sagen
fakt ist zwischen mainz und koblenz gibt
es auf rund 80 flusskilometern keine
einzige brücke für autos die einzige
möglichkeit über den fluss zu kommen
sind sechs fähren von halb sechs morgens
bis halb zehn abends pendelt momentan
die fähre zwischen sankt goarshausen und
sankt goar eine möglichkeit die rein
seiten zu wechseln
die andere auf der straße bis nach
koblenz flussaufwärts und dann wieder
zurück rund 70 kilometer
für laura heuchemer unternehmerin aus
der region keine frage
die brücke muss kommen für uns wäre es
halt eine erhebliche vereinfachung des
verkehrsflusses modelle für einen
brückenbau gibt es bereits auch wurden
schon mal kosten überschlagen damals
sprach man von mindestens 40 millionen
euro das ist aber auch schon wieder vier
jahre her
ja es ist halt auch schon so ein ewig
langes thema also ich sag mal allein
mein verstorbener vater hat schon vor 15
20 jahren
dieses engagement in gremien halt für
die mittelrheinbrücke sich stark gemacht
ein paar kilometer oberhalb von sankt
goarshausen auf den taunus höhe liegt
der familienbetrieb den die
mittdreißigerin zusammen mit ihren
beiden geschwistern vom vater geerbt hat
verpackungen aller art stellen sie her
als unternehmen hier oben auf dem taunus
ist die infrastruktur einfach das a und
o und es geht ja nicht nur um die
straßen die wir hier brauchen um eben
unsere güter von a nach b und zu unseren
kunden zu bekommen
es geht ja auch um mobile also mobilfunk
wir haben hier sehr große funklöcher
leider wir brauchen schnelles internet
damit wir uns auch schnell mit unseren
kunden verraten können obwohl die
voraussetzungen nicht ideal sind allein
der nächste autobahnanschluss ist
dutzende kilometer entfernt wollen sie
weiterhin hier bleiben als arbeitgeber
verbunden mit der region immer voll
hoffnung auf investitionen in die
infrastruktur also auch gerade das das
raumordnungsverfahren jetzt aufgenommen
wird für die mittelrheinbrücke ist halt
wirklich ein ganz entscheidender schritt
um halt eben von der politik in signal
zu setzen dass sie halt auch wirklich
dran sind diesen ja infrastruktur
knotenpunkt hier halt einfach zu
erleichtern
investitionen allgemein in infrastruktur
und speziell im brückenbau für alle fünf
im rheinland pfälzischen landtag
vertretenen parteien ein entscheidendes
thema was die mittel rheinquerung
anbetrifft lassen sich die parteien
durchaus voneinander unterscheiden
spd und fdp bekennen sich zu dem
geplanten vorhaben oder dem anstehenden
vorhaben die planung steht ja noch aus
das gilt ähnlich auch für die cdu gegen
eine neue brücke im mittelrheintal ist
nur eine partei die grünen im
unterschied ist an zieren sich ganz klar
von diesem projekt sie möchten keine
brücken bauen auch aus angst um den
unesco welterbestatus des oberen
mittelrheintals denn bislang ist nicht
abschließend geklärt welche auswirkungen
ein brückenneubau
hätte die afg profiliert sich
demgegenüber regelrecht als brückenbau
partei weil man ganze sechs neue
rheinbrücken fordert einen ersten
schritt hat die politik nun mit der
eröffnung des raumordnungsverfahrens
gewagt doch ob die mittelrheinbrücke
tatsächlich bald gebaut wird steht
völlig in den sternen
deshalb werden die menschen zwischen
sankt goarshausen und sankt goar wohl
weiterhin die fähre nehmen müssen auch
noch lange nach der landtagswahl